- [Voiceover] "Tickets for a
play were $2 for each child
"and $4 for each adult. At
one showing of the play,
"one adult brought 4 children
"and the remaining adults
brought 2 children each.
"The total ticket sales from the children
"and adults was $60. How many children
"and adults attended the play?"
All right, this is an interesting one.
OK, so let's just think
about how much was spent at the play.
We know it had to add up to $60,
but let's think about it
in terms of the children
and adults and their admissions.
So, you have this one
adult right over here
that brought four children.
So, how much is this family,
let's assume it's a family,
how much are they going to spend?
Well, that one adult is going to spend $4
for their own ticket, and
then four children at $2 each.
So, plus four children times $2 per child,
this is going to be $8 on
the children's tickets,
plus $4 on theirs, they're
going to spend $12.
So, that adult is going to spend $12.
And then there's some remaining number
of adults that brought two children.
So, let's say, r is, I could
say the remaining number
of adults, or, let's say,
adults with two children.
Adults with two children. That's r.
So, each of these adults
with two children,
how much are they going to spend?
Well, they're each going to
spend $4 on their own ticket,
for the adult, and then
they're gonna have two children
at $2 each, so they're going to spend $4
on the children's tickets.
So, they're going to spend $8 in total.
So, each of these adults
with two children are going
to spend $8 at the play.
And there's r of them.
So, they're going to spend $8 for each
of these adults with two
children, and there are r of them.
So, this is the total
amount of ticket sales
from the adults with two children.
And you add that to the tickets sales
from this one adult
with the four children,
and they're gonna have to add up to $60.
So, this is going to
have to add up to $60.
Let's see, we can subtract
12 from both sides,
and on the left we'll be left
with 8r is equal to 60 minus 12 is 48,
divide both sides by eight,
you get r is equal to six.
So, we want to be very careful.
You might say, "OK,
there were six adults."
These are just the
adults with two children.
There are six adults with two children,
but there's another adult.
There's another adult who
brought four children.
So, there's a total of seven adults.
Seven adults total, pardon my handwriting.
Seven adults total.
So, we could just look at these choices.
Only one of these choices
have seven adults.
And we could verify that
this would also amount
to 16 children.
Because this person up here, in magenta,
they would bring four children,
so you would have four children,
plus six adults brought two children.
Six adults bringing two children each,
that would amount to 12 children,
and that indeed does add up to be 16.
If you're under time
pressure, you can see,
look, there's only one
choice that has seven adults,
so you can just pick that one.